Tổng thống như đúng là Trump trong 2 ngày 2020 và 2h30a mấy mồn đã tiến hàng liên tiếp 2 cuộc địa đàn quan trọng với chỗ tịch Trung Quốc tập cả bình và tụi những bản và sát đế tạc chi trong buổi cảnh tăng thẳng ngoại giao Trung Nhật về vấn đề đạo Đại Loan tiếp tục ra tăng trong cuộc gọi đồ tiên 2020.
Ông tập nhấn mạnh về ông Trump rằng Đại Loan trở về Trung Quốc là một phần có lỗi Trump trở tự thế giới hậu thế trên 2 trong mắt gình.
Đúng thời gian gọi Trung bị ý dưới chỉ đã cả thiện quan hệ. Truyền thống đã nước Trung Quốc cũng đồng gọi nhấn mạnh thông điều trụ quên có đỏ lập vấn đề không thể mặt cả.
Tuy nhiên, trong bài đăng trên mặt sâu, các nhân trưa sâu sâu nói về kết quả địa đàn.
Ông Trump không thể để cập tự nội dung đạo Đại Loan, mà chỉ nói quan hệ 2 nước rất mạnh mẽ và 2 bên đã tiến trên về quan hệ thương mạnh.
Đất hiểm và kệ sốt mà tuy phê tán yên.
Trong cuộc gọi thứ 2, chúng ta hàng làm thống mi một thủ tưởng nhất mà ta kai chỉ đã có diện Trung Trump.
Đây là cuộc chào đổi nổ tiên giữa hình yên lạnh đạo kể từ khi bà hiện bắt kinh nổi rất sau trên mũ phản nấu quan sử nếu Trung Quốc tình công đạo Đại Loan.
Bà ta kai chỉ nói, ông Trump hàng định 2 bên rất thần thiết và bà của thế gọi tróng bất kỳ lúc nào,
lữ thu tưởng cuộc trò biết trong địa đàn.
Ông Trump đã giễ dãn ngọn quan hệ miệ chung, sông cuộc chẳng nhất đến căng thẳng Đại Loan Trung Quốc.
Dời phần tích nhật, vì vậy đang quan ngại Washington có thể giảm uống hộ Tục Kio trong bình địa này.
Các cuộc hội đàm giễ dã trong bối cảnh bộ ngoại gia Trung Quốc này hàng đưa thống mấy một chỉ trích kể hoạt Tục Kio trên kai tên lửa phần không,
tại đạo, lúc nào của đi, cảo vực nhật hư khích quân sử, Tục Kio thì hàng định còn định quan hệ miệ chung, lại yêu tổ sống con, với anh em khu vực.